the democratic party is in a spiral of
hatred and reaper and
and
hate and recriminations because joe
manchin said the same thing he's been
saying all along which i'm not going to
sign on to a 5 trillion bill
so yesterday the white house was ripping
on mansion and then shinsaki was asked
about ripping on mansion and she said no
regerts got a big tattoo across her neck
that said no regards here is jen saki
white house press secretary
is there any regret uh within the white
house or within discussions with
democratic leadership just about how
this negotiation went given that
statement from him that he feels that
he's been badgered and beaten
well that certainly is not our objective
never has been our objective but
our objective is getting this
legislation passed and reminding uh the
american people and all people who uh
could vote for it what the stakes are uh
so no we don't have regrets about uh
aggressively communicating about it and
making sure people understand that if we
don't pass this legislation costs for
the american people will go up and
economic growth projections will not go
in the right direction
regards no regrets she's got no regrets
at all
i i i'm amused by the fact that the
democratic party is now using republican
talking points with regard to this bill
it's going to lower your it's going to
lower your costs it's going to stop
inflation and good luck with those
arguments guys meanwhile joe manchin
fired back he's like yeah lady um
i'm from a state called west virginia
that your president lost by 40 points so
no
i'm not blaming anybody i knew where
they were and i knew what they could and
could not do
they just never realized it because they
figured surely to god we can move one
person
sure that we can badger and beat one
person up surely we can get enough
protesters to make that person
uncomfortable enough they'll just say
okay i'll vote for anything just quit
well guess what i'm from west virginia
i'm not from where they're from and they
can just beat the living crap out of
people and think they'll be submissive
period
okay so um there's joe manchin this is
over the the biden white house they're
trying now they're trying to claw back
today they've been like well you know
joe biden personally didn't insult your
man you think mansion cares like joe
biden has this great wonderful
relationship with joe biden yeah good
luck with that joe biden joe manchin
he's like you know the reason why i
rejected their bills because they kept
giving me the same bill over and over
and over and they just kept lying about
it
the same bill i have in front of me
right now that they kept putting in
front of me was the same six trillion
dollar bill from the beginning the only
thing that changed was the time element
which they would pay for things and i
said that's just in genuine to tell
someone's getting a tax credit it goes
away in one year
okay so meanwhile the progressives in
the party they're thinking like should
we just get rid of joe manchin like
please keep doing this please keep
whittling your party down so
representative pramila jayapal she uh
she's one of the leaders of the
progressive caucus
and uh and she says you know joe biden
told me that joe manchin was committed
i'm so surprised i'm so shocked really
are you though because um
you shouldn't be
it was a complete stunner a complete
shocker because the president told me
that senator manchin had committed to
that framework that the president
unveiled to us right before he went to
cop26
and that that was the framework that the
progressive caucus then endorsed
all of which prompted wolf blitzer to
ask jayapal do you think the mansion
even belongs in your party mansion
apparently is considering going
independent
which in west virginia is a smart move
didn't hurt bernie sanders to be an
independent socialist in vermont so if
manchin goes independent he will still
win elections in west virginia then he
gets to be the swing vote by the way if
joe manchin becomes a republican he
loses all power right then he's just
another republican from a red state and
probably not the most right-wing
republican in west virginia like not
even close because he's kind of a
democrat right so him going independent
is still a real possibility and then he
gets to decide every single election who
he caucuses with the republicans or the
democrats but here's will flitzer
suggesting that the democrats expel him
yeah please go for it guys do it
senator manchin says he'd like to think
there's still a place for him in the
democratic party do you think he still
belongs to the democratic party
go for it man really do it
i mean if aoc had her way they would
aoc yesterday she can always be counted
on for the stupidest possible analysis
of any given situation because she of
course has the brain wattage of a frying
pan uh she says that these you know the
big problem here is that the senate is
an old boys club
someone should tell that to kirsten
cinema who's the other vote dude not do
this here's aoc
what we really need to do is crack down
on the senate which operates like an old
boys club that has a couple of gals in
it that have managed to break through
and we need to actually institute some
institution we actually need to
implement some institutional discipline
if people want to threaten to to block
ambassadorships if they want to threaten
dysfunction they actually need to show
up and do it
man do it man this party is so
dysfunctional so
the party's platform come 2022 is
coveted shutdowns mass testing mass
panic
high inflation ripping on the
independents who won't vote for your
massive stupid bills
and
then jabbering to msnbc
2022 is gonna be real bad for democrats
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bid in some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video